bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj che oggi siamo
ritornati nella mia vecchia casa perché
mi ero stancato di milano ho cercato un
po di rimettere le cose come erano tutto
il casino del demonio parco perché non
sta sui tagli delle tecniche bellissimo
avere cioè se un po a rifarlo preso un
video vecchio per avere proprio la
qualità dello sfondo vecchia tanto io di
qua non mi muovevo quindi alla stessa
cosa non lo so se è uscito questo trovo
spero di sì che lo dai
figo o no fare questa premessa a parte
gli scherzi perché volevo dirvi una cosa
che sta una cosa molto seria dopo li
trovi che vi ho fatto sarete felici
comunque perché sta per iniziare anche
per i nostalgici lo scarta gioco dei
pacchi cose los cartacea di pacchi lo
scagioni pacchi e la serie che di più mi
ha fatto conoscere miss a youtube
la serie non un videogioco dove io
ricevevo i pacchi che fanno inviavano e
li scattavo in diretta quindi tra poco
inizierò a fare video sono scattate dai
pacchi se volete che io apra il vostro
pacco in diretta che frase brutto da
dire ma andate un pacco all'indirizzo
che trovate nella descrizione di questo
video inviati vostro parteciper fa vj
insomma sopra così capiscono niente dire
che possiamo cominciare con il video di
oggi siamo ritornati raga su my friends
pedro che non so se ve lo ricordate quel
giochino bellissimo dove tu puoi sparare
a far andare al rallenty le cose aveva
battuto macellaio e volevo continuare un
po per vedere cosa ci avanti ma i fan
pedro teoricamente pentro e la banana
mamma mia ragazzi ma devo fare una cosa
incredibile e ci provo ci provo perché
ci credo non ci avrei mai fatta colpirlo
come si è aperto come ho fatto la prima
sta roba porco demonio mi sono fatto
malissimo
lei va a eco sparato alla roba che pirla
palladino se riesco a fare una roba
decente
buon giorno ciao franceschi morto
ok raga questo sarà difficile lo dico
mamma mia a matrix d'amico nomi siano i
calci perfetto non so ha ricordato cioè
oddio no ho rischiato come la morte nome
si rompe la scatola ragazzo rischiato
veramente tanto ci provo mamma mia come
splittato male i colpi sono morto e me
lo merito
non sono morto non so come sia possibile
questa l'ho fatta veramente male lo
stesso motivo non si sa per quale motivo
mi hanno graziato
già quando giri e bellissima cover a
vivo come allora qua la vedo difficile
raga io lo dico è finito livello invece
proprio un sesto senso per le cose
difficili before brava mamma mi ha
proprio la scena più brutta di tutte mi
hai messo che ho sbagliato a fare tutto
quello che ho fatto ma non sarà
bellissimo mi ricordavo fosse bello ma
non così tanto
allora credo che qua si inizia a fare
sul serio e non vorrei dire cagate ma
secondo me conoscendo quel gioco
mamma mia ho fatto una cosa incredibile
per una volta questo posto mi mette i
brividi fai bene zio perché sto per
arrivare io
[Musica]
credo che ci sia non c'era solo lui a
nove righe c'era un altro l'ex co let's
golf di sotto non mi hanno visto la mela
city è scemo dai come hai fatto a non
veder v6 orbo ciao mamma mia ragazzi
ecco pianti amici è voluto un attimo ma
sto riprendendo esattamente tutta la
skill che avevo bravissimo bilico
bravissimo da solo perché per una volta
me lo merito
madonna a caccia calci vada lui pirla
stavo morendo per niente porca vacca
meno male che ne sono accorto barile non
so bene cosa serve non c'è nessun nuovo
scherzavo c'è qualcuno o mio dio d'oro
ho fatto un casino peccato saperli
numero non è detto che sia morto non
sono morto ragazzi sto sopravvivendo all
non so come come non detto mi sono
buttato di sotto c'è non sono morto per
di spari ma sono molto perché mi sono
buttato di sotto giusto mi sembra ovvio
ma c'è anche lui sì lo prendo ragazzi
perché da un po che non minuto però
aspetto di averne due per usarlo a noi
cielo 2
ciao tempo testo perfetto wall jump
spingsteen l'ho fatto nuova incredibile
allora flip lever non sono anche bene
cosa devo fare per ok
mamma mia con dominarci spina è
veramente film ve lo dico con le morto
la 8.000 poi vorrei ben vedere non ci
arrivò mai non c'è league ormai ci sono
arrivati e non ci sono bravissimi ce ne
frega bravo rufy di colpi forse fisico
alpi raga che cambiare arma porca vacca
come in corso d'opera mi fa cambiare
armate un casino questa ragazzi sta
diventando veramente difficile c'è
rispetto al primo video che ho fatto è
tutta un altra roba completamente
diverso next level se contento amico mio
pedro mataj possono rimbalzare i colpi
varamente addirittura far rimbalzare i
colpi maledetti i cacciatori di taglie
poi perché c'è una taglia sulla mia
piazzano capisco proprio
manco stessi facendo nulla di male oddio
calcio in bocca e via e passa la paura
l'hang seng e tese vabbè dai vabbè
allora fai tu ding ding ding di certo
fare
ma com'è possibile come possibile
bellissima sta roba comunque basta
petron amministrare lo so come si fanno
le cose c'è pedro sottolinea che mi dice
come schivare i proiettili però non lo
vedete voi voi dico io però lo so come
si siano i proiettili perché mi ha preso
per un novellino sono otto volte che
faccio videogioco non è vero la seconda
potrei dimenticarmi però fai bene a
ricordarlo porca vacca mio dio non muori
oggi non morirò oggi o facendo cose
strane perfetto non sono morto alice la
vita c'è la vita se la vita sua vita
grazie qua un casino ragazzo o blog è
stato stranissimo occhio c'è gente
ancora che se ne fregano di lei al
complete sono stato bravo before bravo
che sa la vedo difficile suo nome siamo
arrivati al punto in cui diventa
complicato però calcia nello stint
veramente hanno messo il pompa sto male
non bastano basta suo gioco diventato
incredibilmente interessante ma anche
doppio nave singola pompa però va bene
ma la mia e pompe incredibile no raga il
pompa non dovranno nesta me lo faccio un
casino che fa fuori tutti in una volta
sola ma state scherzando
dovevate metterlo molto prima 12
ricaricare anche loro ce l'hanno porca
vacca aveva un sacco leva veramente un
sacco
l'ho preso non è morto però bellissimo
mamma mia ke bello una goduria tam tam
ecco l'unico problema è che col tempo
non posso sfruttare i colpi perché ciò
sono in mano la sony non intendevo
quello ma non mi so spiegare perché in
italiano a volte esiste a volte no è
come si scende era meglio non scendere
senti amico panara non è che puoi farmi
tipo dall'assistente maestro cioè nel
senso che spari anche tu proprio tu devi
sparare non è che devi sono seguirmi nel
mio pensiero siccome questo quale banale
se le sogna di notte è impossibile
cosa c'entra la bara uno skateboard o si
va beh no vabbè ma veramente ci posso
usare lo skate film fest e che che finco
che è andato per terra camei o con lo
skate board ragazzi però è difficile
starci sopra
mamma mia che male o mio dio con lo
skate board sta dire cioè ogni volta che
vai avanti sto gioco pensi che non possa
andare meglio di così invece aggiungono
cose ogni volta migliori più pazzesco
guarda che poi fare tutt'altro non è
neanche semplice da usare cioè devi
proprio starci sopra macello madonna a
posto
tutto ok tutto giusto tutto bene non so
cosa ho fatto ma vabbè eccoli
probabilmente devo lanciare la roba di
milano per far esplodere però non sono
sicuro ma l'ho fatto quindi va bene ma
gianpi scape puoi saltare
mammamia questo sarà nel replay finale
radio ve lo dico sicuro praga e
bellissimo lo skate board bellissimo
soprattutto perché non mi sono salvato
per cava che al contenuto sarà morto
porco demonio come ho fatto a cadere mio
dio
salve tranquillo level complete band
mi sa che siamo arrivati al boss ragazzi
lo vedo il babbo natale di turno
salve brothers beni in one offre a lui è
preoccupato addirittura pensato mi
facesse pensavo fossi tutto cassuto in
grado di farmi fuori tantissimo a ecco
devo farlo fuori ma veramente aspetta
che qua c'è un tavolo dello sviluppare
mi sembrava che fosse così semplice no
che male fa malissimo
c'è pure gente in tutto c'è una boss
battle dove c'è altra gente forza vacca
anche nell'altra c'è l'altra gente brera
che era molto più lineare
questa è la vedo difficilissima ma
potete ricaricare la mia manna dal cielo
vai o 33 colpi di sto finendo alcuni del
bomba ma non c entra
mamma mia dai da temi della vita per
favore che sono messe male
la mia mamma viaggio rischiassi però sto
coso trasmetto dell'esm ha non per le
basi che lo dico
sarà gestendo la torretta incredibile
mamma mia che fastidio
arriverò al momento in cui riuscirà a
farla fuori stato retta maledetta ma
l'etica è il club che non colpire da
dietro
mammamia siete pazzi per usare così
dietro praticamente siete pazzi si va
bene
sono passare tutto il pasto pare però
schiva capperi ragazza poco manca poco
dai non è vero che è male niente negli
scopi affari danno ho fregato che brucia
camere giuria e schiatta è morto non
letti dichiara way ho capito che faccio
spesso buttato dov'era lui ei ragazzi
questo ramo my friends pages numbers per
episodi vi sia piaciuto però anche il
terzo che sta diventando sempre più
incredibile lo vedete dove l'ho
interrotto in rete idea di come stia
diventando figos è veramente già grafico
all'inizio mammamia assurdo diventa
incredibile io spero vi sia piaciuto il
video lasciato un bel commento mi piace
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciate con la
campagna di una bellissima gretel i
sotto perché serve per rimanere
aggiornati sui dove sono gli arrivano
notifica e noi ci siamo come sempre
hanno proseguito per ragazzi
[Musica]